screw with me bellows or what you're
gonna shoot me that's right you only
shoot on our man episode 12 Honey I
Shrunk team flash yeah and kill that guy
did you bury learns that big sir his new
friend and iron Heights actually is
innocent he was found guilty of shooting
a guard but there was no apparent motive
the reason why he's in iron Heights was
completely because of another person
that team flash discovers this is man
named silver running and silver run
Dayne a KA dwarf star has the ability to
shrink things yeah of course celerity
ensues when our when our team goes out
try to stop him and two of team flash
members get shrunk down to a couple
inches big you okay guys we're two
inches tall Caitlyn this is ridiculous
and so Barry puts the team on trying to
find run Dean and stop him and and prove
that Big Sur is innocent you guys
hamster cage I think they can read minds
Cecille horton finds out that she has
developed sort of like women to develop
gestational diabetes she has developed
gestational telepathy maybe this will
turn out to be a good thing I've always
wondered what goes on in that head of
yours
heart rates 170 BPM and there's no sign
of dark matter in the amniotic fluid so
the baby's not a matter nope it's a
perfectly normal baby girl
you were gonna say baby girl I'm having
another daughter I'm gonna have a sister
I guess we can cancel the announcement
party
boy girl that's 50/50 assess your skills
for real what number am I thinking of
three 11:25 three again
Bulbasaur what the hell is a Bulbasaur
it's so weird why would I be thinking
about Pokemon it's time like this yep
definitely a telepath but how if the
baby is not a meta then where did these
powers come from nope I wasn't on the
bus
no I was not abducted by aliens no I
didn't inherit a mystic totem for my
grandma really guys why are you still
thinking about Bulbasaur's he's the
cutest one of all okay
my best hypothesis is this is actually
triggered by your latest phase of
pregnancies and it's actually latent
dark matter that's been in your brain
since maybe the first particle
accelerator explosion think of it like
gestational diabetes right but it's
temporary I mean the symptoms should
recede after childbirth
hey everybody brand-new flash tonight
Goldberg is back and he is the mayor of
iron Heights
in case you didn't remember the person
that he says his bellows who's giving
him [ __ ] is the actual mayor of Central
City who was found to be corrupt back in
episode 4 because of that whole
elongated man thing that was going on
since killing you didn't work out but we
agreed upon 200k let me have the
photographs here's the pictures don't
forget to there's all those bus metas
that we haven't run into since we've
been in there but this episode is mostly
about him helping Goldberg's character
get out of prison and if you didn't spot
it there are a whole bunch of Goldberg
wrestling Easter eggs on his license
that they flash on-screen I can't
remember which matches exactly but it's
September 1999 in September 2003 those
correspond with a couple of his big
matches he was in a couple of different
Federation's like he went from WCW to
nitro to WWE so if you're a huge
wrestling fan you might know exactly
which matches those were anytime there's
someone big like Goldberg that they get
for the show and they flash a bunch of
numbers on screen usually they reference
what they're famous for in real life the
character that he's playing from the
comics is obviously a little bit
different his name is doofus P ratchet
but he debuted during flash 3:38 back in
1984 I couldn't find any of those
numbers anywhere on here but his comic
book character is kind of hilarious so
you can understand how they made him a
little more badass for the TV show but
now that we have
Goldberg on the flash we've had edge
back during season 2 and we have Cody
Rhodes on arrow well if the petition
stephen amell to use all of his juice as
one of the lead actors of the shows to
get these actors on screen together for
some sort of wrestling moment unrelated
to flash stuff we also found out about a
new superman TV show that's happening on
the DC streaming service where the
Titans TV show is gonna drop I'll talk
about that at the end of the video
because it's unrelated to flash TV show
stuff all the shows are a little bit
complicated when it comes to the new
stuff that they're developing but on the
flash this week villain confirmed to be
dwarf star who's actually a villain from
the atom comics who has like a shrinking
belt that's how he shrinks stuff down in
the TV show it seems like he's using the
gun to do that so he's more of a tech
based villain than being a meta so I'm
guessing that he's not one of the bus
metas just from the footage that we've
seen but they also give us the tip-off
on cecile getting pregnancy powers he
uses the example of gestational diabetes
diabetes not a good thing to have so I
don't know necessarily that he's trying
to imply that Cecile's powers are a bad
thing like there's something bad behind
it but again I think it's all in service
of them teeing up the idea that iris
gets powers she becomes a speedster for
a single episode and they're like oh my
god how is this happening but surprise
is probably that it's because she's
pregnant and she developed those powers
because of what's going on with Barry's
children so like remember back during
episode 10 where she was able to hold
herself in the Speed Force in bullet
time with Barry while everybody else was
standing still
so quickly that everyone else is still I
actually don't know it's probably just
an early form of what's going to be
happening to her later like her being
able to harness the Speed Force because
of the pregnancy so all the evidence is
just pointing towards iris getting
pregnant but no idea which episode that
they would figure that out and it sounds
like they would do the speedster iris
twist before they reveal the pregnancy
like why would this happen oh my god
this is amazing
okay I'll try to help out so they have
that episode where iris gets to be a
speedster but then come to find out oh
my god I'm pregnant we're gonna need
more diapers that might be later on this
season but it all circles back around to
mystery girl who is probably either
their daughter or granddaughter we keep
saying dawn Allen but we don't know
where she's from the timeline so that
will just depend on what name they give
her but right now I still think it's his
daughter not his granddaughter but just
remember there's still a number of
directions they could take that big
tip-off she said her motto was always
pay it forward there's actually an
episode with later to this season that's
gonna be titled pay it forward so yes
she's gonna be a much bigger character
later on but to explain that new
Superman TV show this is actually a
pretty big deal the news broke while I
was making this video so if you guys
didn't know the Titans TV show is gonna
be dropping later this year we don't
have an exact date for that but it's
debuting on the DC streaming service
that we're just calling DC Direct right
now they don't have an official name for
it we don't know when it's going to
launch but it's the Netflix Style
service the DC Comics and Warner
Brothers are launching where they're
gonna premiere Young Justice season 3
the live-action Titans TV show and now a
Superman prequel series that's going to
be called metropolis that's what they're
calling it I don't know if that's gonna
be the actual title but it's supposed to
follow Lois Lane and Lex Luthor before
Superman became Superman in Metropolis
and wait for it this will make more
sense it's being done by the same people
that started doing the Gotham TV series
although I don't know who's actually
going to be running the show but they
got a 13-episode order it's guaranteed
for 13 so they're already doing it they
say they expect it to premiere during
2019 so it's probably going to be the
end of this year before we see any
concept footage or anything like that
but just keep in mind what Gotham looks
like the way it's said around that city
and how they might do a metropolis
series that feels a little bit like the
later seasons of Smallville
in the way that they were in metropolis
but Superman was not Superman yet they
didn't say anything about how they're
gonna deal with the Superman character
if he's gonna be in Smallville while
this series is going on if he's gonna
come visit them every once in a while
like Clark Kent comes to Metropolis on
occasion because I don't think that you
could do a series like that without
doing any version of the character you'd
have to do some form of Clark Kent they
haven't announced any cast we don't know
if any of the Smallville people will
come back for that or if any of the
Supergirl people will crossover because
they're kind of doing a version of that
TV show on Supergirl right now but I
think part of the idea is that it's
gonna be a little bit more hardcore
without straying from the tone of what a
Superman TV show should be like there's
a very specific tone for Superman stuff
you don't want to go too far from that
it's just that they're gonna focus more
on the lex luthor character in the Lois
Lane character speaking of Smallville
they actually made a really funny Tom
Welling Superman joke on Lucifer this
week why are you doing this understand
you first your strengths your weaknesses
because everyone has a kryptonite
lieutenant but I'll say there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter just be a subscriber
and share the video using those tools on
the watch page I'll name the winner when
I post my flash episode later tonight
click here to rewatch that ant-man and
the wasp trailer that just dropped and
click here for more brand new flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight